the headquarters of MSAD, the the
international intelligence service of
Israel, which is inside Tel Aviv. It's
in the northern part of Tel Aviv, but
it's in the city. It's in a densely
populated area. Uh, and of course, the
concern is if you're firing, even even
though Iran might consider that a
military target, it is in a densely
populated city. Uh, and what does that
remind you of, guys? They are using them
as human shields.
When I give £10 in charity and it is
consumed, the rewards come to an end.
However, if I give to a rak, then you've
put your money into something permanent,
which means a endowment that continues
to give on your behalf until the day you
meet Allah subhana wa ta'ala. Subhan
Allah. That is amazing.
I legacy, brothers and sisters. We want
you to build a legacy with your where
will your donation be going? Events,
global events inspiring the iman of
millions around the world. Education,
free Quran lessons, free lectures, free
reminders. Number three, media content
for kids, educational shows, spiritual
Islamic shows online, brothers and
sisters. Go to the link inshallah and
donate in this blessed 10 days
inshallah. May Allah bless you guys.
Asalam alaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends. So you guys all may have
heard the attacks that were made against
Iran by Israel and subhan Allah. Some of
them call it preemptive but as you you
guys know subhan Allah that they are the
transgressors. Yes. uh they were
unprovoked and they attacked Iran and
they've been making this excuse for a
long time now. There's similar post from
30 40 years ago. Iran's got nuclear
weapons or whatever it is for that
matter. The only one that is the biggest
threat to the whole world brothers and
sisters with nuclear weapons is Israel.
And mark my words guys uh when the
oppression carries on and the whole
world has enough of them. Best believe
it that these individuals who are so so
Zionist we're talking about here who are
so vile who do not care about any human
life and sisters they will be using
those very nuclear weapons they have
which they are hiding they have they
will use it against anyone who tries to
threaten their oppression they you might
they might call it their existence but
subhan Allah here are some videos
brother and sisters and not only that
we're going to come to Netanyahu running
off to Greece with his private jet uh
subhan allah so let's go to some clips
inshallah where Iran has sent uh
ballistic missiles and not only that it
they actually overwhelmed the defense
system the iron do defense defense
system by Israel. So um basically they
have overwhelmed Iran overwhelmed u the
system by sending drones. Drones yes and
then sent ballistic missiles. So uh here
is it in let's watch in to be honest
I'll be honest with you guys uh I
believe they are worse as each other
with all due respect Iran with with his
funding his k 500,000 Sunnis were
massacred. So let's get this very clear
and simple. I'm not here on anyone's
side, okay? Iran has killed far more far
more than Israel has ever had. But
still, it does not mean that one
oppressed are killing the other. They
have and this is a reality. We have to
be objective. We cannot take sight. This
is a reality that's happened. Hisbah was
funded by Iran and they killed thousands
of innocent Muslims, Sunni Muslims.
Subhan Allah. Not that it matters if
they're Sunni or not. Whichever innocent
life has been killed. So, here are some
footage of, Subhan Allah, the
headquarters of Mossad being hit. And
this was reported by Fox News. So we're
going to watch inshallah uh those uh the
the video. Trey Yinst has been up all
night is standing by with all the
details. Trey, what can you tell us?
Yeah, Laura, following that Israeli
attack against Iranian nuclear
facilities and top IRGC leadership
overnight and into today, the Iranians
have responded with three waves of
ballistic missiles. This is Israel's
version of the Pentagon, the Kira. And
the building on this compound was just
hit. Please go back. Go back. Please go
back. Please. You You can understand
here. It's very tense at this specific
location because the Iranians are now
targeting the defense establishment of
Israel. And so I'm going to have my
cameraman pan up here to this building
just across the street from the curio.
And so
so that is the Fox News reporting of the
Mossad headquarters being hit. And here
is some other footages of what was
happening in Tel Aviv. view that among
the targets were Israeli airfields, but
also, and this is crucial, the
headquarters of MSA, the the
international intelligence service of
Israel, which is inside Tel Aviv. It's
in the northern part of Tel Aviv, but
it's in the city. It's in a densely
populated area. Uh, and of course, the
concern is if you're firing, even even
though Iran might consider that a
military target, it is in a densely
populated city uh with civilians around
it. And that's just one more layer of
escalation. And what does that remind
you of, guys? They are using them as
human shields. they are their main moss
headquarters are all around. It's like
having uh the the the MI5 building or
wherever it is in a densely populated
area in the middle of central if I'm not
saying there MI6 building there is
somewhere in central London. Yeah. But
they it's using like human shields.
You're using it. This is what you call
human shields on a mass scale. Okay. And
this is exactly where you look where the
iron dome is being fired within those
places. Subhan Allah. So even if Iran
wants to attack military bases, you can
see that there will be civilian
casualties and that is exactly what
they're doing. So that's what they say.
Every confession, every accusation is a
confession. Here is more footage
inshallah um of the attacks that
happened and the damage that were caused
in Tel Aviv.
[Applause]
Shabbat. Yo yo yo.
So long. Yo
yo
yo.
Here is a footage of mass amounts of
Zionists who are gathering in one
specific location. which I don't know
why. Running for their lives. Let's
watch it for ourel.
[Music]
Uh, okay.
Go
on. Yo, I need
I need I need him. Yo, I need the shock.
I need [__] shock.
And he's [__] the shock. The Zionist
is in shock. He He's in shock. Is he in
shock when they're killing massacring
50,000 innocent people? Nope. Can you
imagine the the audacity? I mean, what
was you expecting? You know, I'm not on
anyone's side in this matter, but this
guy, oh, I'm in shock. I'm in shock. I
don't understand what you expecting. You
go and mass you commit massacre, kill,
women, and children. Go and attack a
sovereign nation. And when they
retaliate, I'm in shock. I'm in shock. I
mean the level of um
it's just it's just like it's as if
they're thinking that we can do whatever
we like. The arrogance subhan Allah that
they have. Yes. The it's just
unbelievable. It's just unbelievable.
And here's another few other footages in
[Music]
I mean in a nutshell brothers and
sisters while this is going on where is
Benjamin Netanyahu the Satan were there
uh may Allah destroy him inshallah into
pieces where was he bros and sisters
this is from the Jerusalem post it says
that the wing of Zion Israel's own
version of air force one took off from
Bengurian airport on Friday morning as
Israeli init as Israel initiated an
assault on Iranian nuclear facilities as
part of occupation operation rising
lion. Israel media reported the aircraft
which serves Prime Minister Benj
Benjamin Netanyahu and President Isaac
Herszog uh as may Allah destroy them in
the pieces in this life and the
hereafter I mean as the official vessel
of transportation during international
visits departed from Athens Athens on
Friday morning amid fears of an Iranian
retaliatory attack. The aircraft was
also also previously flown out of the
neatim air base in the northern neg
during Iran's attack on Israel in April
2024. So as you can see they do their
attacks and they save their backside and
they go to Greece. Yeah. Shortly after
wing of Zion departed from departed for
Greece. IDF spokesman Brigen Effie
Derfin told a press conference on Friday
morning that Iran had launched over 100
drones towards Israel. So they they run
for their life. The IDF has not
officially confirmed that every single
drone was shot down and there could be
many more launched. But at this time
enough was shot down to make the home
front instructions temporarily more
lenient. The instructions could quickly
become strict again at some point and if
Iran Iran launches another large attack.
So as you can see the coward Benjamin
you can run away from the drones. How
you going to run away from Allah
subhanaa tala's punishment? Like Allah
says in the Quran do not think that
Allah is unaware of what the evildo
doers do. He only delays them for a day
when their eyes are going to stare in
horror. Brothers and sisters, believe
me, the punishment that you would want
Benjamin Netanyahu here of him being
destroyed or whatever, his life is going
to end once. Allah has something in
store for him better. Let him carry on
his transgression. And never, never is
there going to be peace to them. Yes. To
the Zionists with the oppression. The
whole world has woken up to the reality.
Yes. And alhamdulillah, we make dua that
those lands are returned back to
Palestinians so they can live with the
Christians and the Jews that they lived
for centuries of years. Zionism,
brothers and sisters, is not Judaism. So
subhan Allah, let's make that
distinction inshallah. And there is
nothing else to be said, brothers and
sisters. May Allah subhanaa tala deal
with the oppressors and we I will be
informing you guys in the days to come
and the hours to come of the escalation
inshallah because we have news that Iran
is going to have another wave of attacks
towards Tel Aiv. Till next time,
brothers and sisters, asalam alalaykum.
What better?